vous dites qu'il y avait deux tireurs
face à Kennedy
bonsoir William Raymond bonsoir Billy
solestis donc William Raymond vous êtes
journaliste auteur notamment de Dominici
non coupable les assassins retrouvés le
livre qui a servi de base au téléfilm de
TF1 et dans lequel vous émettez
l'hypothèse qu'en fait la famille
d'anglais la famille Drumont n'a pas été
assassinée par Gaston Dominici ou par
l'un de ses enfants mais par les
services secrets voilà c'est une thèse
qui est très critiquée mais qui a quand
même séduit TF1 puisqu'ils ont fait le
thème de leur deux téléfilm exactement
pour des raisons complètement fausses et
qui prouvent encore une fois que les
journalistes télé lorsqu'ils font des
articles ne lisent pas les enquêtes et
on m'a reproché des choses qui étaient
en téléfilm en pensant que je les avais
écrit moi alors que c'est pas du tout le
cas voilà donc en tous les cas vous avez
été à l'honneur le soir de suite sur TF1
et aujourd'hui votre thèse sera sans
doute aussi critiquée mais nous avons la
deux experts qui sont donc une solo ils
vend le blog qui ont déjoué Thierry
Messant je crois la première seconde oui
on a tout de suite cru que c'était de la
flûte voilà par rapport à mes 100 j'ai
vu l'émission d'ailleurs par rapport à
mes 100 je me suis retrouvé souvent face
à lui dans des émissions dans des débats
pour dire un avion c'est bien écrasé sur
le Pentagone j'habite aux États-Unis
j'avais vécu ça quasiment en direct et
bon c'est Thierry Messenger je ne suis
pas Thierry Messenger
de la chance d'avoir deux observateurs
qui sont habitués aux manipulations
voilà alors le bouquin s'appelle JFK le
dernier témoin c'est publié chez
Flammarion alors sur la bande rouge sur
le livre il y a marqué assassinat de
Kennedy enfin la vérité donc là voilà
alors le dernier témoin c'est c'est vous
monsieur Billy solestis donc
milliardaire texan ruiné et longtemps
financier du président Lindon Johnson
que vous accusez d'avoir fait tuer John
Kennedy pour qu'il arrête de fouiner
dans les magouilles de Johnson c'est ça
est sortie dans Paris Match elle sera
développée lundi soir dans lundi
investigation sur Canal+ sous le titre
JFK autopsie d'un complot voilà alors on
va reprendre les choses de zéro pour que
tout le monde comprenne bien et tout le
monde puisse suivre alors le 22 novembre
63 John Fitzgerald Kennedy est assassiné
à Dallas quelques heures plus tard lit
Harvey Oswald est arrêté mais il est
immédiatement abattu par Jack Ruby avant
d'avoir eu le temps de s'expliquer voilà
assassin de l'assassin voilà alors la
révélation du livre que vous publiez
tous les deux c'est qu'en fait il y
avait un deuxième tireur
Oswald n'était pas seul dans le dépôt de
livres au cinquième étage en face de
l'endroit où Kennedy a été assassiné
auprès de Lui dites-vous il y aurait eu
un autre tireur un dénommé Malcolm
Everett Wallace tueur au service du
lobby pétrolier texan tueur dont on a
retrouvé l'empreinte digitale sur place
donc déjà prenons ce point vous dites
qu'il y avait deux tireurs face à
Kennedy
il y avait deux tireurs l'un d'entre eux
était Malcolm MC Molos et
l'autre c'était
qu'est-ce qui vous permet de dire que
Wallace était là ce jour-là au cinquième
étage du dépôt de livres c'est le point
de départ en fait de l'enquête c'est la
découverte en 98 d'une empreinte classée
par les enquêteurs de l'époque classé
anonyme et lorsqu'on la compare à un
suspect qui va être mal comme Wallace on
se rend compte qu'on est plus grands
experts américains trouvent 33
points de comparaison aux États-Unis
faut savoir six points de comparaison
suffisent pour envoyer quelqu'un à la
chaise électrique il y en a 33 donc
cette empreinte elle est formellement
identifiée on sait pour des raisons
techniques je peux expliquer ici qu'elle
a été déposée au moment du crime donc
c'est la preuve qu'il y avait à côté de
lire Oswald un deuxième tireur à Dallas
le 22 novembre 63 qui est ce Malcolm est
vrai twallace qui donc était auprès de
travailler pour Lindon Johnson je
connaissais déjà dans les années 40
c'était déjà un tueur à gage et c'était
un très bon tireur d'élite
il avait commencé à travailler dans les
années 40 pour le lobby il était à
Marshall chérie à l'époque
le conseiller du prince c'est lui qui a
mis en place le réseau politique de
Johnson c'est lui qui faisait les la
connexion entre Johnson et les et les
financiers Texans donc ce Malcom Wallace
était un tueur à gage au service du
lobby pétrolier texan on est bien
d'accord et il était à côté d'harvé
Oswald le jour où Harvey Ostwald a tiré
c'est ce que vous dites c'est ce que je
dis
suivi par des documents alors autre
révélation de votre bouquin Kennedy a
été touché de face en fait on le voit
bien quand on voit les radios de son
crâne il a été touché de face et quand
on voit des photos de Kennedy on
s'aperçoit qu'il a un visage intact ce
que vous dites dans votre bouquin c'est
qu'il a été réparé par un embaumeur de
génie du nom de John liguette qui
d'ailleurs n'a jamais dévoilé son emploi
du temps le 22 novembre 1963 donc
Kennedy a subi une réparation faciale
avant le top 6 pour accréditer la thèse
du tueur unique en fait ce qu'il y avait
depuis toujours il y avait une
contre-verse entre les témoignages des
gens qui avaient tenté de le sauver à
Dallas et les gens qui avaient fait
l'autopsie à Washington plus tard et les
témoignages officiels certifiés ne
correspondait pas moi un jour on me
parle Billy me parle de ce John liguette
un bonheur réputé qui a travaillé sur le
corps de Jane Mansfield lorsqu'elle
était décapitée et lorsqu'on va prendre
la première fois je me dis ça y est on
est parti dans X-Files parce que là
c'est un petit peu fort mais je retrouve
la femme de ce de ce liguette qui me
raconte que le 22 novembre 63 elle
s'intéresse pas du tout à la faire
Kennedy quelques quelques minutes avant
que la maman de cahier soit lancé on a
appelé liguettes en la on lui a dit on a
besoin de toi pour faire quelque chose
sur le président et il pendant 24 heures
et lorsqu'il va revenir après il dit
maintenant on part tous de Dallas il
émet tous dans la voiture toute sa
famille il se retrouve dans le sud du
Texas il se met devant la télé il fume
cigarette ce cigarette et lorsqu'il voit
lire vos Vald se faire assassiner il dit
maintenant c'est bon on peut rentrer
cette histoire là était extrêmement
forte et pour moi le demander
vérification parce que je peux pas
sortir une histoire comme ça sinon
j'allais passer encore pour un fou et
donc j'ai retrouvé la personne par
exemple qui ce jour là est parti avec
liguette et quand on lui demande ce
qu'il faisait le 22 novembre 63 il dit
je ne m'en souviens pas je ne m'en
souviens pas je ne dite pas ce que vous
dites est faux mais je ne m'en souviens
pas donc vous ce que vous dites c'est
que liguette ce jour-là a réparé le
visage de de Kennedy pour faire croire
qu'il avait été tué par un seul tireur
finalement ça serait l'explication la
plus simple et la plus logique de la
différence entre lorsqu'on voit le film
nous apprroudeur le film où il explose
faut dire le film de 26 secondes qui est
le film unique de l'assassinat Kennedy
réalisé par Monsieur zapproudeur
pour la première fois en France dans le
dans le documentaire lundi on va montrer
une version qui a été nettoyée de
manière digitale et on voit bien toute
la partie avant la tête de Kennedy
tomber et lorsqu'on voit les photos il a
plus rien donc c'est une c'est pour moi
l'explication la plus simple même si au
départ me paraissait folle bien alors
c'est exactement ça c'est une histoire
toute simple les gens essaient de la
rendre plus compliqué qu'elle ne l'est
en fait l'histoire est toute simple
alors bref le complot selon vous a été
organisé par le vice-président Lindon
Johnson qui trouvait les frères Kennedy
trop curieux il pensait que les frères
Kennedy s'intéressaient trop à ses
affaires
Billy à l'époque où vous étiez riche
vous avez considérablement arrosé le
président Lindon Johnson qui était
encore un politicien local vous l'avez
aidé vous avez été en contact avec
Johnson vous avez été son financier à
l'époque
c'est vrai oui effectivement l'indice
que vous donnez dans le bouquin
malheureusement vous le donnez à la fin
et on espère lundi soir sur Canal qu'on
en apprendra plus dans lundi
investigation vous possédez Billy une
cassette ou Cliff Carter qui est donc un
membre de la du réseau disant du lobby
Johnson vous dit textuellement Lindon en
parlant de Lindon Johnson le
vice-président Lindon n'aurait pas dû
donner à Mac c'est Wallace l'ordre de
tuer Kennedy
oui j'ai cette cassette
lorsque nous avons enregistré cette
cassette Clifford avait peur de
d'avoir des problèmes donc on a des
enregistré cette cassette avec les
moi-même
d'assurance vie pratiquement alors si
jamais j'ai un problème j'envoie un mot
à mon avocat et la bande sera prend du
public donc ce que vous nous dites là
Billy c'est que c'est une cassette dans
laquelle Cliff par cœur dénonce Linden
Johnson comme non pas l'assassin mais
enfin en tous les cas l'organisateur de
l'assassinat de John Fitzgerald Kennedy
yes c'est exactement ça
organisé
compléter l'assassinat alors
c'était une affaire un peu trop
compliqué pour eux ils l'ont délégué à
des tueurs professionnels
ne savaient même pas ce qui était les
enjeux c'était des gammes il se disait
que les Kennedy c'est des gamins de
Boston qui savaient pas ce qui se
passait
Hélène nous avait une question à poser
demander à Monsieur pourquoi il en parle
qu'aujourd'hui pourquoi vous en parler
qu'aujourd'hui Billy
la seule raison pour laquelle j'en parle
aujourd'hui c'est que bon certainement
j'ai eu d'autres occasions par le passé
mais
il y avait à l'époque
Johnson ce qui avait fait l'histoire de
sa vie de la mienne et les assassinats
étaient que des accidents de parcours
mais maintenant les frères Kennedy
ils auraient dû se méfier du clan texan
il n'avait n'était pas de taille à
affronter la cour des grands
texan Lindon avait besoin de se
débarrasser des frères Kennedy parce que
d'ailleurs justement
lui-même il passait la chaise électrique
les gars alors vous dites aujourd'hui
bon vous êtes vous êtes ruiné un Billy
je crois qu'on peut le dire vous êtes
veuf vous êtes assez âgés et vous dites
je vais tout dire mais pourquoi ne
dites-vous pas tout pourquoi dites-vous
seulement cette phrase de Cliff Carter
Lindon n'aurait pas dû donner l'ordre
pourquoi est-ce que vous balancez pas
tout compte tenu de votre âge et de
votre situation
les dernières années de ma vie en tôle
quand même
et pourquoi faites-vous ces révélations
en France plutôt qu'aux États-Unis
par le passé mais
quand William a commencé à travailler
sur ce livre
on s'est on s'est rapproché ça s'est
passé très simplement je faisais
confiance à lui bien alors William Jean
lecieux dans Télé 7 Jours affirme que
les révélations de votre livre sont déjà
dans le domaine public et trouvables en
30 minutes sur internet il dit il suffit
d'aller sur Google de taper Billy
solstice plus John Kennedy et on y
retrouve tout ce que vous avez mis des
années à déniché
du documentaire excusez-moi parle du
documentaire et pas du livre qui n'avait
pas encore lu Jean Le sur nous fait un
procès d'intention sur ce sur ce
documentaire là pour des raisons
complètement fausses et personnelles et
moi ce qui me choque le plus dans ce
dans cette espèce de mini polémique
lancée par Télé 7 Jours qui n'est pas
suiv le reste de la presse qui a vu le
documentaire qu'il a adoré ou qui a lu
le livre et qu'il aime ce qui me choque
le plus avec Jean leieur c'est que c'est
quelqu'un qu'on a eu au téléphone
Bernard Nicolas et moi pendant plus
d'une heure à lui expliquer que la
première personne avoir parlé de Mac
Wallace c'était moi dans un précédent
livre en 97 et que c'était cette
information
là qui avait été reprise sur Internet et
comme je lui avais dit mais savez-vous
monsieur ce qu'on dit sur vous sur
Internet est-ce que ça veut dire que
c'est vrai il était resté sans voix il
nous avait expliqué aussi que il est
extrêmement sensible à tout ce qu'on
disait sur les États-Unis et que donc il
avait pas aimé notre documentaire c'est
son endroit de pas aimer mais ce qui est
choquant c'est que ces arguments sont
complètement faux enfin vous savez quand
même William que depuis 40 ans il y a eu
de nombreux théories du du complot qui
s'opposait aux conclusions de la
commission Waremme il y a eu Jim
Garrison popularisé par le film de
l'hiver Stone lui parlait d'un dénommé
Kley show agent de la CIA qui aurait été
en fait l'assassin et puis il y a eu des
centaines d'ouvrages où les
commanditaires ont été tour à tour il y
a la mafia Castro les soviétique
l'extrême droite
Johnson enfin il y a que la famille
Ewing qui a pas été accusée
il y a un prochain livre qui se prépare
qui accuse à la famille bouche je vous
le dis donc non c'est vrai la
littérature Kennedy est immense je crois
que c'est un des sujets qui a le plus
été traités là je pense que pour la
première fois un journaliste me disait
ça que lorsqu'on finit le livre on ne
ressort pas avec plus de questions qu'au
départ moi la dernière phrase du livre
c'est demain je serai ailleurs parce que
pour moi j'ai le sentiment que cette
enquête là je l'ai terminé
il reste il reste des il reste des
questions forcément parce que parce que
j'ai pas la prétention de répondre de
répondre à tout mais pour la première
fois le c'est un livre qui est constitué
d'énormes d'énormément de preuves il y a
il y a un cahier photo vous avez des
annexes avec des avec des documents
totalement inconnus et de témoignages de
gens qui étaient au Texas qui n'avaient
jamais parlé et 40 ans après il parle
pour la première fois
[Musique]
votre version serait la bonne
parce que j'avance des preuves
parce que j'avance des preuves et ça
c'est une c'est une première tout le
monde est parti dans des théories là
vous avez des documents vous avez la
cassette et surtout j'ai pu prouver que
mélissol était celui qui disait et une
fois que vous prouvez que bilisol est
vraiment le un conseil Johnson vous
pouvez le croire et puis j'ai entendu
j'ai entendu cette cassette enregistrera
71 ou Clift Carter explique linon
Johnson a donné l'ordre d'abattre
Kennedy
[Musique]
voilà donc William Raymond et Billy
sollicie ce livre s'appelle JFK le
dernier témoin c'est publié chez
Flammarion est-ce que vous avez des
questions les archives les archives de
la CIA elles sont pas ouverts toutes les
50 ans aux États-Unis vous savez les
archives il faut pas trop fantasmer
dessus parce que les archives on limer
ce qu'on a bien envie d'y mettre sont
des traces écrites ce sont des rapports
l'assassinat de Kennedy c'est pas décidé
par écrit il y a pas de courrier il y a
pas de correspondance
détruit tout ce qui pourrait incriminer
quelqu'un il le balance bien merci
beaucoup la suite c'est lundi dans
quelques semaines vous démontrer de
parapluies que votre livre je vous le
souhaite
arguments
c'est lundi soir sur Canal+ ça s'appelle
lundi investigation
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
innarditube abonnez-vous et mettez un
pouce bleu